hi this is Mario with Meijer math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video what
we're going to talk about okay is how to
work with some more challenging log
expanding and condensing type problems
you can check out some of my past videos
about working with logs and expanding
and condensing and the different
properties and rules there but in this
video what I wanted to do is just show
you some more challenging ones that you
might encounter in your class or just
when you're working with math problems
using logs so two examples the first
example we're gonna do is an expanding
one so you can see there's a lot going
on in here and at first it might look a
little intimidating but let's see if we
can break it down to make a little bit
simpler so what we're gonna do is we've
got log base three of this whole thing
first thing we're going to do is we're
gonna recognize that when you have the
fourth root ok so we're working from the
outside end when you have the fourth
root that's really like saying this is
the one fourth power okay so I'm just
going to get rid of this radical and I'm
gonna think of it as a fractional
exponent so when you have a power okay
you can use the power rule for logs and
you can bring that down in front of the
log so this can be written as one-fourth
log base 3 of X minus 1 cubed okay times
X plus 1 to the 1/2 power so I'm
changing this square root to a
fractional exponent a rational exponent
all divided by 5x ok so you're with me
so far the next thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to recognize that when you're
multiplying you can write it as a sum of
logs and when you're dividing you can
write it as a difference of logs so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna continue
on with this expansion we've got 1/4
times the log base 3 of X minus 1 cubed
plus the log base 3 X plus 1 to the 1/2
power minus the log base 3 of 5x now I
did - because we're when you divide you
subtract okay and then remember when you
have this power here you can bring it
in front of the log as a coefficient
okay so we're gonna do that okay so I'm
just gonna write this as three here and
I'm gonna write this as one-half here
okay all right with me so far okay then
what we're gonna do is I'm going to
distribute the one-fourth okay into the
bracket here okay into the parenthesis
so this is going to be three fourths log
base three of X minus one okay plus
one-fourth times 1/2 is 1/8 log base 3
of X plus one okay minus one-fourth log
base 3 of 5x and then this 5x you can
expand this further as well five times X
we could think of that as a product and
we could write this as log base 3 of 5
okay plus okay so I'm just going to put
parentheses here plus log base 3 of X
and then go ahead and distribute the 1/4
in here the negative 1/4 so this would
be negative 1/4 log base 3 of 5 minus
1/4 log base 3 of X okay and we can
bring these other terms down so 1/8 log
base 3 X plus 1 and 3/4 log base 3 X
minus 1 okay so there you go that's your
final expansion now if you want to check
your work and just for practice what you
might want to do is take all of this
here and go ahead and condense it you
should get back this original problem
that we started with there okay so
that's expanding that was a tough one
but notice what I did is I started from
the outside and I worked my way in okay
if I have radicals okay I converted them
into rational or fractional exponents
however you want to say that and then I
use the product and quotient rules
product you add quotient you is dividing
but you would subtract the logs ok so
let's look at this next example here
here we have this expanded okay
logarithmic expression we want to
condense it all down into one logarithm
so how do we do that well okay what
we're going to do is we're basically
going to do what we did here in
reverse okay first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to bring up all the
coefficients as exponents so if I see a
coefficient I'm just gonna bring it up
as a power here okay so I'm just
bringing those up okay
okay like that so in our first step what
we're gonna do is we're gonna write this
as natural log of 2 cubed which is 8
okay
- natural log of the square root of 5x
because the 1/2 power is the square root
okay
plus the natural log of the cube root of
7 because a 1/3 power is a cube root ok
minus the natural log of X okay plus the
natural log of 2x all to the fourth
power which is 16 X to the fourth minus
natural log of X minus 1 okay so we took
care of the coefficients we brought
those up as powers using the power rule
for logs but now what we want to do is
we want to look at everything that's
subtracted ok when you subtract logs
that's going to be the same as when you
divide them so it's the quotient rule
and you subtract you divide when you add
you multiply so the wood what happens
here is anything that's added is going
to be in the numerator multiplied
together those arguments are going to be
multiplied anything that's subtracted is
going to be divided it's gonna go in the
denominator and those arguments are
going to multiply together so we're
going to condense this all into one
natural log here so follow me on this
we've got natural log of 8 okay times
the cube root of 7 okay times 16x to the
fourth so those are all the positive
logs the ones that were added / ok the
ones we're subtracting which is the
square root of 5x okay
ax + X - 1 now I would continue to
simplify this down a little bit more 8
times 16 is 80 plus 48 is 128 so we have
the natural log of 128 X to the fourth
cube root of 7
all divided by the natural log is not
going to be divided okay it's just the
argument okay so that's a common mistake
students make X times X minus 1 times
the square root of 5x so this is fully
condensed and if you want to check
yourself or just practice I would take
this quantity and then go ahead and
expand it and see if you get back to the
original expression there so I hope this
more challenging example helps you to
understand logs better go ahead and
subscribe to the channel if you're
enjoying these videos and you're
benefitting okay and I look forward to
seeing the future videos check out some
of my other past videos on logs if you
want to additional help and I'll see you
in the next video I'll talk to you soon